[Music]
everyone this is Nick on the program
moderator a manager of the forties at
Vayner X and what you're about to watch
right now is a very special episode of
our last 40 s hosted here in New York
City now if you've been following along
240s at all you know that these are
confidential behind closed door sessions
but everyone so out would get the
sign-off of everybody in the room so
these are the six top takeaways from our
last session of 40s in New York City
enjoy
[Music]
never ever be at the mercy of something
else
so why I'm the best at my craft I don't
want to be a mercy of my own employees
it's why I got my hands in absolutely
everything
what if they quit what if they get sick
well if they get bored
what if they win the lottery that's
literally how I think about everything
that's why I'm in everything I don't
micromanage but I'm dangerous enough in
everything cuz I don't want a point of
failure your point of failure is called
Google they literally change it no
matter how evergreen and white hat
you've been they just might decide that
video content is part of their macro
strategy so what what I always think is
when you got something working always
have a nest egg of 20% of your money and
energy of building up other things that
if God forbid your ad goes to zero
you're on the course of being open good
news I stood upon this company September
and rolled out a new vision called the
Vayner volume model 98% of them thought
I was out of my mind didn't believe in
it at all thought that I'm like the
crazy founder and like I'm silly but
like when it becomes real this you know
lead anytime you have full buy-in from
your employees you're in a dangerous
place it means there should be some sort
of friction from somebody who's leading
up in front and sees everything and is
driving a company versus people that
work in it who are in the like they're
different like my job is to be like oh
[ __ ] there's an iceberg I'm gonna move
this way and everybody who's downstairs
is like what do you mean the water's
been super clear the whole time I'm like
no no there's an iceberg but they're in
the [ __ ] basement they're like it's
been such a nice [ __ ] ride like this
has been so smooth leaders need to
understand what's happening next
employees are executing on the current
and overvalued the past
here's the thing back to just because we
have a TV advertiser and here's my big
thing with TV advertisers TV works like
people seek like as much as I struggle
with the concept of commercial like they
see results they just have never spent
the money that they spend on TV on a
proper digital execution to compare the
two this is why this is why I still run
direct mail and some stuff for my dad
and other businesses and I look at it
like to me it's not about does something
work or not work
it's the Delta of perfect execution in
both the only TV thing that scares me
against Facebook is Super Bowl that's
why I keep talking I mean I believe in
Super Bowl the most yeah whether it's
220 and you can imagine that's hyperbole
like what I know is the following if you
are in a hardcore
if you are a perfect executor of current
digital the margins are unparalleled to
anything else bro you can do one YouTube
pre-roll video that hits paydirt
creatively against search google
activity of people searching for fixing
the roof or placing like all the things
we can all imagine if God forbid okay
God willing you have a Dollar Shave clip
like video that converts on YouTube it's
in perpetuity it's it's it's why I love
ads Google and Facebook will always take
your money they're gonna change your
organic
they're building that brand I'm gonna
have a second location a trophy for
building my brand
that's way book when that isn't the same
thing you're doing now stay the course I
was literally the video posted yesterday
on Instagram
I've been saying for the last six months
a lot randomly and [ __ ] like this I
don't understand how people understand
that the thing that you [ __ ] did to
get you there is the thing that gets you
to the next level but people think once
you get to a level now you got to change
it yeah I think that's when you got to
double down on it
people change once they get some level
of success like notice my reactions I'm
like whoa you got to spend more second
location same it's very funny how humans
work like they find something that works
this is like in health and fitness this
is in business and for some reason
there's this need to find something else
when you've just shown yourself what
works so yeah yeah it's like am I
missing there's this insecurity am I
missing something that could be better
when something's clearly working you
know I feel I always used I always think
about I don't know why this is the
analogy I always bring it up it's like a
fruit from a tree it's like here's a
beautiful [ __ ] huge orange tree in
the back of your yard you're pulling the
orange and you're only squeezing like
30% of the juice out and you like this
delicious [ __ ] orange juice and
you're like should I grow an apple tree
like no [ __ ] like squeeze more
oranges
[Music]
everybody should have a podcast because
podcast is easy you just interview
people it's actually remarkable how
scary to me podcasting is everybody
should have a podcast and the amount of
people in this room that are trying to
get to somebody that they can't get to
but now instead of asking for their
business and a cold email or a LinkedIn
they email and say I want you to be a
guest on my podcast and get that in a
minute and now you got a hole now you're
hosting the party
oh and I know you guys have heard this
from me like you're not here if you
haven't consumed my content I say the
same things over and over because it
works the only way to build a personal
branded b2b is to bring value to the
decision makers that has nothing to do
with your direct business let me say
this because it'd be important for a
couple of you if you think about it the
my audience for Gary Vee the last six
years seven years was not mapping to
what vaynermedia was doing and even
Sasha and even four DS has been a very
passive execution for me because I feel
like it's starting to bleed into the
people that do follow me right the way
you gain credibility is when the content
is bringing value to the audience when
it's not a lead gen for your business
when we read the newspaper advertorial
sections don't get us as excited as the
regular the reason I've been successful
is I've been able to provide value
without expectation in return of
business and if the karma or serendipity
or if you're friends with the CEO of GE
and you're like you should meet this got
like the serendipity of the right event
worked out so let me explain what I mean
by that there's reasons why your
business is successful if you started a
podcast or started making white papers
or putting out content on LinkedIn which
is where you should live you need to be
thinking about who you're trying to
reach which is the decision-maker who
drives private-label you should almost
start a podcast called the private label
show but every guest should have nothing
to do with your industry a show about
private labels is not a show that exists
and is directly attributable to your
business now
interjecting when you interview another
female executive some of those nuances
may be a smarter way to integrate it
than making it the pillar of the content
I don't have a jet show I don't have a
garage sale show but I do show my other
parts of my life in my content see where
I'm going what I like about you
interviewing other people who are the
private label provider to Costco for
shrimp frozen shrimp and she gets to or
he gets to tell you the story of how
they did that
now you're just creating a halo of
private labeling which inevitably is
gonna lead to you the number one thing
you want to do when you're in b2b
content marketing is never make your
content about what you're selling and
always make so much value for the
audience that they click your profile
and they do the homework of what you
sell that's what I do that's what works
I'm not asking for the business I'm
putting out as much value in the world
I'm gonna either be right or wrong about
TV marketing I think I'm gonna be right
and as that continues to play out that's
only leading to more opportunity not
less but I'm never asking people for
their direct business in my content
[Music]
you